[Music]
it's great I mean it's it's amazing for
many reasons one is because I am a big
fan of blanking - because it's like the
most expensive movie I'll ever have
anything to do with probably so that's
throwing we get brownie points for being
the voice of Pumbaa and laughing like
this here honest takes fire you I'll be
honest
there was some time where we would
practice Hakuna Matata together and I
got to be Timon and it was amazing I
will say I'm sure Billy Eichner has a
much better voice than I do but I was so
excited but it's really exciting and I'm
just hoping I'll be in the same room
with Beyonce one what's your question
what are you gonna ask her because I
can't ask her can we be friends now she
said you did
Hakuna Matata runs with one another she
was Timon you were Pumbaa yes how are
you preparing for that to bring your
unique spin I might be done the movies
not done but I think I am personally
done overall it's it's surreal it'll be
weird how surreal would it be if you
want a Grammy with Beyonce and all the
Glover I mean the pressures on but we
just can't wait for the Lion King collab
of our dreams
[Music]